&gt;&gt; I second that. Thank you very A and L Creations, this is a wonderful addition
to the event. So now it's time to move into our chemical senses.
&gt;&gt; Wait. Andy, should I be worried? Should I be, are things going to be blowing
up? What's going on?
&gt;&gt; Lauren, before you run to get your hazmat suit, the chemical senses are just
senses that are based on the reception of chemicals. So for example, your sense
of smell or your sense of taste.
&gt;&gt; Oh. So, with smell, the tiny particles that go up your nose and that are
detected by your smell receptors?
&gt;&gt; Exactly. And something pretty similar for taste, actually. let's actually go to
Susan, who is, yep, sounds like she's on location at the taste-off now.
&gt;&gt; Thank you, Andy. Although the taste-off will focus on our senseletes' ability
to activate their 10,000 tastebuds. The person who's going to excel in this
competition is the one who also activates their smell receptors.
&gt;&gt; It's truly amazing how our perception of taste actually depends on the
sensation of taste and smell.
&gt;&gt; It really is. How is it possible that these two seemingly different senses are
so intimately related?
&gt;&gt; Well Andy, that's because both taste and smell are processed up here, in the
frontal lobes of our brain. For the taste-off the contestants are going to have
to identify samples that contain each of the five basic flavors. These are
sweet, salty, sour, savory and bitter. To do this we'll be using the following
ingredients. Sugar, salt, lemon, MSG, and tonic water.
&gt;&gt; And Susan, which ingredient is going to correspond to which flavor?